another area where political action
should be brought to bear
another concern that i would wager very
few of you
have ever been informed of even though
you may subscribe to the better
newspapers and magazines
is the importance of converting the
world
to a hydrogen economy
when people talk about the energy crisis
what they usually are saying is well
we need to go to nuclear power
but it's so mutagenic and destructive
and hard to control that it pollutes the
atmosphere and screws up the food chain
that's bad and then the nuclear
engineers come forward and they say
well did you know that if you replace
nuclear power plants with coal-fired
generation that you will have to have so
many coal-fired power plants
that the natural radioactivity in coal
will eventually be concomitant to the
amount of energy released by
nuclear and then people say fusion
they say and if you just give us another
five trillion dollars
we think we can deliver fusion by 2030.
this is obviously not a solution
meanwhile
it is very well understood in the
engineering community
that sunlight gathered in space
could be transmitted as microwave energy
to let's say a remote island
somewhere and on this island
hydrogen could be cracked out of sea
water
and the liquid natural gas
transportation technology that is in
place
today to move liquid natural gas from
indonesia
to its markets in japan and europe that
high pressurized highly pressurized
tanker technology
could be used to move hydrogen to its
markets
well when when you use hydrogen as a
fuel
you crack it out of sea water when you
burn it in an automobile or an
electrical generating plant
it recombines with the oxygen that it
was broken away from when it was cracked
out of sea water
it turns back into water you have here
a very low pollution fuel economy
and the other amazing thing about a
hydrogen-based economy is
all machines that we possess today
will work you can convert
automobiles generating plants
uh steel smelting facilities
heavy industry it could all run on
hydrogen
well why is this not being explored and
pushed
i i don't understand is it because the
investment in the standing
crop of nuclear and coal-fired
generating systems
is so great that nobody wants to turn
away if that's what it is
then again what we're pushed up against
is profit
we can solve our problems
but it's not clear that we can solve our
problems and get rich
at the same time and that is the current
requirement for all solutions if you
come up with a solution to a problem
that doesn't make
money on the side they say it is not a
solution
this uh means that the profit motive
they're saying well we could save the
world if you'll show us a way to make
money at it
but if you can't show us a way to make
money saving the world then we're just
going to keep doing what we're doing and
let it slide and apparently
uh the wealthiest five percent of the
human race will escape
to a terraformed mars or a colony at l5
and the rest of us will be just left
down here to eat it
it's happening right now the greenhouse
effect
is at last being measured and commented
upon
in the boardrooms of the banks and
internet
national lending institutions not
because they love the earth
but because they see the
uh food production economy of the
northern hemisphere
going to hell they see the great plains
of america
and western china and the soviet union
turning into deserts
that's their investment they're now
ready to talk reform
and in the argument about is the world
getting better or getting worse
uh the main fact that is always put
forward and by myself i might add
to argue that the world is getting
better is
in the last couple of years there's been
a phenomenal number of wars
and conflicts negotiated to stalemate
uh the situation in angola namibia
the situation in iran iraq the situation
in central america
the situation in afghanistan to some
degree
each one of these situations has been
slightly backed down
from its previous high level of conflict
i believe this
is not because decency and
reason has broken out in the
chancellories of the world
it's because they're looking at data
about the greenhouse effect and the
dissolution of the ozone hole
and what the data is telling them is war
is as obsolete as putting armored men on
horseback on the plane of gold
war is a luxury of ancient
overwealthy societies we can't afford
war that's why it's being legislated out
of existence
a staggering amount of money is going to
have to be spent to try and keep this
planet from going nova
and you know we may end up paying the
brazilian government
ten dollars a throw to plant trees
i would favor that i would rather pay
the third world to plant trees even if
we spent
billions of dollars on it than to build
up nuclear
arsenals that seems to me a much to to
leave
our children a reforested planet than to
leave
our children an ever larger arsenal of
thermal nuclear weapons seems completely
reasonable to me
but so my
my hope is that the word has finally
trickled up
to the top and that they are willing to
talk
turkey i think that the situation is
going to
get worse as a prelude to getting better
and that as psychedelic people who can
only live on this planet for the
foreseeable future
we are we need to network with each
other
and clarify our thinking on these issues
so that when the crunch comes we will
not be scattered
and demoralized and frightened
because i think it lies not that far uh
in the future so
i just want to put these things out
you've never heard anything
like this publicly from me before
and i'm not saying that we need to
become
burning-eyed fanatics and say if this
isn't done
then x y and z which is terrible
will result but i think we have a moral
responsibility to articulate
solutions even though they may not be
the ultimate
solutions because if if what these
governments
fear is the uh
turmoil from the world population when
they try to
implement vast global changes
i think we need to give these
institutions
the understanding and permission to
realize
that the great masses of people are far
out in front of them
because it's the great masses of people
who feel the impact of these things
in the boardrooms of new york the
greenhouse effect is simply
bad data on return on capital investment
in brazil in the midwest it means
bankruptcy
lost farms disrupted families ruined
lives
alcoholism drug abuse serial murder
the whole spectrum of effects that
happens when people
are asked to live in intolerable
social conditions and
you know one of the things that's always
been at the back of my mind and sort of
upsetting to me about the the new wave
of psychedelica
and the old wave as far as that's
concerned is
it's awfully lily white i mean it's
really a honky party and
it shouldn't be that way because the
world is not lily white
i mean the world belongs to
25 year old black women with three
children and an average annual income of
somewhere around
six hundred dollars that is the average
citizen of this planet today or maybe
she's chinese
but if we take seriously the leadership
position that our good fortune
has laid upon us and the least fortunate
among us
in this room is more fortunate than 98
of the people on this planet if we take
seriously our position of privilege
then we have to begin articulating
these kinds of programs and i don't hear
it
being done i don't want to talk about it
very much
but i think this political campaign
that's being run is
infantile and insulting beyond belief
and i've knocked michael dukakis
and had people come up to me afterwards
and say
you shouldn't say that this is going to
be a very close election
you should if you've got a criticism
wait till it's over with
we've got to get this guy in well
i it's co-option as far as i'm concerned
i mean what kind of a political uh
trap have we fallen into
when the guy who is our best hope
his wife was a pill head for 25 years
and he never noticed
and that's our last best hope you know
that's the giant
who will lead us out of the morass
and i like the guy i'm
but it just shows you you know
what a appalling situation we are asked
to put up with
and people care passionately that he win
i hate it that i care whether he wins or
not
because i hate it that i have to even
spend time thinking about whether i do
or do not support
such a clown and yet the other side is
so
ghastly and so forth and so
on it's like an infinite regress into
horror
where where
are the people with ideas well
the answer is probably half of them are
in this room
and uh and yet the ideas are good ideas
they're
sound ideas what this political campaign
seems to be about is
not saying anything about anything until
it's over with
and then of course we're and we who are
asked to support dukakis are told
don't make demands on him don't
criticize him
elect him and when he's elected you'll
find out that he's really tim
leary marshall mcluhan and mikhail
gorbachev
all rolled into one i don't believe it
i don't believe it so
uh i think that we shouldn't
it's almost like a coincidencia
positorum it's almost
like a union of of opposites
we must radicalize ourselves
on the surface without changing
our psychedelic transcendentalism which
is the source of our great strength
personally when and in the 60s what we
always
saw was that
power corrupted an absolute power
corrupted absolutely
i mean i remember situations where you
know we would surge
forward and stone the pigs and bust
the windows and then the leadership
which was usually you know these people
who stammer
the leadership hubert humphrey said an
amazing thing the only amazing thing he
ever said as far as i could tell
he said my enemies are people who
stammer
and i really had to laugh because i knew
exactly what he meant because i had
heard these
little round-faced fat boy politicos
trots and that sort of thing uh
say over it over and over again now now
now now i want to make i
i i just want to make one one point and
you know that bit they their idea
of a riot was you bust a few windows and
overturn a police car and then you
returned to party headquarters to talk
strategy
and they would and we would be left in
the streets when the pigs swept in to
bust
heads so i i i agree with the beatles
who said don't
follow leaders watch your parking meters
in other words you know tend your own
p's and cues
but we need to articulate political
solutions and i think we need to be more
critical
of our own community and i venture into
this area with great trepidation because
i don't want to be
divisive but i think after the article
that the whole life monthly printed
about my comments on crystals
my cover is probably blown
but you know we are tremendously
tolerant
of infantilism as a community
we're basically an anything goes kind of
crowd
and we're not into more uh logical
razors everything is as valid as
everything else it runs the whole
gamut from uh you know psychedelic
research
growth breathing that sort of thing on
into
iridology past life channeling
so forth and so on and again
an infinite regress that saps our energy
and makes us politically impotent
i think we should insist
on empowering transformation
and then work out from the most
politically
implementable solutions toward
these uh more long-term
questionable kinds of positions
that have to be worked out over time
there's a great deal of pontification
in the new age and unquestioning
acceptance and unquestioning uh
preaching of the weirdest stuff
i i'm amazed every time i go into one of
these new age environments
at how little people value
democratic ideals people love
to follow didn't they ever read
jon stewart mill i'm afraid don't answer
that
i mean don't they understand what the
american
experiment is about it's not about
falling down on your face in front
of some bengali weasel who's leading you
to some uh totally interior
vista that does not impact on the
suffering of your brothers and sisters
that's not what it's about the the the
first
psychedelic wave in america was the wave
that created this country
i mean that was a vision so powerful
that even to this day in china
in the soviet union in chile in uruguay
everybody gives lip service to those
ideals i'm not saying they practice it
but every country calls itself a
democracy
every country says it is giving its
citizens
more freedom i mean some countries say
now the way we're going to give you more
freedom is by having three generals tell
everybody what to do
but no country on earth proclaims
we're just power crazy bastards and
listen don't laugh it's progress in the
1930s
there were political philosophies where
that was
up front the strong should rule
the weak should be ground under and
destroyed
that is not a respectable political
position anywhere on this planet
it may be clandestinely and overtly
implemented in a number of places
but no politician can get up and give a
speech
about the need to repress
people and diminish their capacity for
humanness it's just
not in the mix
[Music]
you